the goal of this video is to appreciate
how ideas of natural rights and social
contract and limited government and
popular sovereignty are embedded in
America's founding documents but before
we start looking at the documents
themselves let's just make sure we
understand the context in which they
were written as we enter into the mid
1770s you have the beginning of the
American Revolutionary War which begins
in 1775 a little more than a year after
the beginning of the war
you have the Second Continental Congress
decide to formally declare independence
on July 2nd and the Declaration of
Independence which we will study a bit
in this video is formally approved on
July 4th 1776 which is when we now
celebrate Independence Day even though
some could argue that it was July 2nd
now as soon as the colonies decide that
they are independent from the Kingdom of
Great Britain they have to think about
how do we govern ourselves and so within
roughly a week a little more than a week
after the Declaration of Independence is
approved they start drafting the
Articles of Confederation
remember the Revolutionary War is still
going on eventually what will be known
as the Articles of Confederation go into
effect in 1781
now this Articles of Confederation
really treat the various colonies as you
could almost view it as separate states
that agree to work together for purposes
of getting independence from Great
Britain for purposes of fighting the war
for purposes of diplomacy now over the
course of the next several years it
becomes clear especially through things
like shays rebellion which we will look
at in other videos that the Articles of
Confederation don't provide a strong
enough central government and so in May
1787 you have what is called as a
constitutional convention convening it's
presided over by George Washington who
led the Americans in the Revolutionary
War which they eventually will win as
you see and obviously worse independent
country now and the original intent of
the concept
Convention was to revise the Articles of
Confederation but folks like Madison and
Hamilton were really intent on just
completely replacing it and what they
replace it with was what is now the US
Constitution
which goes into effect in March of 1789
and shortly thereafter you have the
beginning of Washington's two terms
and to be clear the idea of even having
a powerful executive the idea of even
having a president was not present in
the Articles of Confederation that comes
with the Constitution so with that
context out of the way let's look at
especially the Declaration of
Independence and the US Constitution so
here's the beginning of the Declaration
of Independence written by Jefferson and
edited by Benjamin Franklin and John
Adams and I encourage you to pause this
video and first try to read it on your
own and see if you can identify these
ideas of natural rights limited
government popular sovereignty
republicanism and social contract okay
let's read this together now when in the
course of human events it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the
political bonds which have connected
them with another remember this is a
Declaration of Independence they are
dissolving the political bonds with the
Kingdom of Great Britain and to assume
among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature and of nature's God
entitle them so that's starting to refer
a little bit to natural rights a decent
respect to the opinions of mankind
requires that they should declare the
causes which impel them to the
separation so they're saying hey we're
writing this document because we're
trying to show the rest of mankind why
the reasons for which we decide to we
are deciding to declare our independence
from Great Britain we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal let me underline this that
all men are created equal that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
so this is a direct reference to natural
rights in fact the phrase life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness most
historians believe is in direct
reference to John Locke's phrase life
liberty and property when he talks about
natural rights so this is direct
reference to the Enlightenment ideas or
even the pre enlightenment ideas of
natural rights that to secure these
rights governments are instituted among
men deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed alright this is
worth underlining as well because
they're talking about governments being
instituted among men to secure these
rights this is all about social contract
so that's social contract that we form a
government in order to secure rights we
might give it some rights but in
exchange the government has to protect
our rights and they derive their powers
from the consent of the governed so let
me write that let me underline that
actually in a different color derive
their powers from the consent of the
governed that is popular sovereignty
popular I'll just write it is pop solve
popular sovereignty right over here that
the people are the sovereigns that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive to these ends it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute a new
government laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in
such form as to them shall seem most
likely to effect their safety and
happiness so this is more about social
contract they're like look if a
government breaks its social contract we
have a right to replace it and the
document also makes reference to
organizing its powers in such form so
that's really talking about limited
government they're talking about hey
this government just won't have that the
absolute right to do anything so that
right over there is limited government
prudence indeed will dictate that
governments long established should not
be changed for light and transient
causes they're essentially saying look
you shouldn't just
overthrow your government on a whim and
accordingly all experience hath shown
that mankind are more disposed to suffer
while evils are sufferable than to right
themselves by abolishing the forms to
which they are accustomed so they're
saying look you know if you're prudent
you wouldn't just overthrow your
government on a whim but they're kind of
saying we're not so worried about that
because history has shown us experience
has shown us that if anything people are
more likely to keep suffering even when
they should be overthrowing their
government but when a long train of
abuses and usurpations pursuing
invariably the same object evinces a
design to reduce them under absolute
despotism it is their right it is their
duty to throw off such government and to
provide new guards for their future
security so they're saying hey look the
Kingdom of Great Britain they are
abusing us they are usurping power
usurping is taking something from you
that is yours and so we need to throw
off such a government for our own future
security and here it says provide new
guards for their future security so this
provide new guards once again making
reference to limited government